le président l'avait annoncé il ya
quelques jours il faut également
vaccinés à tour de bras pour tenter de
freiner l'épidémie
en plus des centres de vaccination et
des cabinets des médecins généralistes
on mobilise désormais les pharmaciens
dans les officines indre et loire depuis
aujourd'hui il est possible de se faire
administrer une première dose du sérum
astrazeneca que l'on ai 55 ans ou plus
le point avec les cas chopin 22 c'est le
nombre de personnes vaccinées contre la
coved 19 aujourd'hui dans cette
pharmacie d'officine tourangelle a reçu
ses deux premiers flacons d'astrazeneca
et ce vaccin tant décrié n'a pas l'air
d'inquiéter les patients aucune
importance
nous voulions simplement nous faire
vacciner on fait confiance aux
scientifiques lorsqu'ils nous disent
qu'il faut se faire vacciner
soulagé ça s'est fait très facilement
aucune les foules dire aucune aucune
appréhension aucune souffre d'aucune
douleur très bien ici la liste d'attenté
est déjà longue plus de 140 personnes
ont manifesté leur souhait d'être
vacciné et les réticences au sujet
d'astrazeneca sont peu nombreuses on a
prévu ronces vaccination ce matin es11
vaccination cet après midi j'ai un
patient que j'ai rappelé hier soir qui
m'a dit qu'il préférait demander conseil
à son médecin parce que tout à fait
légitime donc voilà il peut ya quelques
interrogations
mais très franchement la plupart des
personnes que l'on voit se diront
confiant sans hésitation
le premier jour de vaccination à la
pharmacie est un succès mais eric d'où
des ne sait toujours pas quand il
recevra les prochaines doses